[Music
] we do this
one for about a hundred years, you know it's really patience
[Music]
well we have to always be attentive to
this
fishing we always don't vibrate for those who
were in brasilia there are 100 every
day we stay here  waiting a very long
time for them to get here it will take a
long time and now I try to
get it so I can do it later I can do it
later
[Music]
the captain fernando magoga count
I am the commander of the 10th company but the
environmental police company
is a lagoon but it is much bigger lake  a
city has approximately 50,000
inhabitants
but the issue of conservation of the hill is
extremely important and extremely
rewarding
these networks here a witch network that is the
main object and of our
inspection today it works in a
way that a very easy area there engages
very much  easy any animal that passes
from another sim to show it will get
stuck in this net there will be a stress
on the animal because the boto  also fishing with a
motorcycle also goes if he lives on the fish that
the fisherman also wants so when there is
this competition everything unfortunately a
goal ends up suffering and really the
relationship in other places
where dolphins
are killed but here he treats the other as a friend
and not  as a rival
I never witnessed another one re-launched the
interaction between yours taking advantage
different right
the fishermen with the dolphins I never
witnessed in another
good place today the popularity of 68 years old and
I don't consider myself old no my name is
wilson francisco dos santos we
fishermen a  team from Alagoas we have been
researching for over 100 years with the
dolphins 2015 year close with the direct line
53 years champion and these fish here
were part of my diet
since my childhood precisely at that
time the fish caught by my parents and my
father was one of
them  same fish that the sewer brings to
the
fishermen fishing with the mouth that is an unpredictable person
I now prepared myself I caught it was
normal because  that bolton arrived because
in this place, which is where we are here,
we ask for the passing fish he is from
pará
there when I go to catch you feathers that
pt will invite people we have to run
after to get there and reach it hasn't
arrived yet  you have to be prepared for
a slap on the hand and already putting yourself on the
edge of the bottom is worth the measure if the
boto soon after the guy is already
sharp with this girl that we keep
pulling, we can always
get a low weight that  they start
hitting the net there and we are dragged
along the land usually it doesn't hurt but when they
catch the fish I see they didn't
catch I always play a good country first
I already fish that with carob games 40
years 45 years already know all the boots
here how to educate works like he is a
part of it, right, it's like a friend a
brother
all the rumors about shrimp I
compare the sewage so jokes like a
dog people have a lot of people in
August and killing the animal is when we
don't see a button that  if he disappears for a
long time here in alagoas it stays like this for a
week the 5th day the guy is already
worried
or is it that this rumor went away this
button died someone killed it is something
like that at the time you don't know what to do
because you are the same thing  who lost
more dear time like this only after he
starts to think what could have
happened to avoid this there
is this here it's just that now until we
go to work out in the hammock which is an r
111 an improvised way for us to be
able to remove these hammocks  that are
illegally placed in the river for
this inspection to work in a
more efficient way we rely a lot on the
collaboration of fishermen,
for example now there was a fisherman who,
when he saw us putting them through now
so far indicated another place that
we will possibly come across  with
this type of network
our unit was empty I am very concerned
about the preservation of the
sewers which is part of the local culture
this year we present  We have five nets
so even with our
intense inspection with this intense preventive activity
fishermen who in the dead of
night at a time when we will not
be present we are not present
they come here to place the net
is to lose 15 15 individuals is a
very impactful thing  for this population
the number is really a
considerable number when it comes to the ones that
today the population there varies from 60 to
40 bots
well the rumors have been dying here
laguna for a long time it
is the last one who died there that
we really missed it was  the electronic
was the one caught with a net he
walked around with a net for a long time and there was
another good one too that dying the other good one
was to accommodate him it's been about 15 years since
20 years ago we've been fishing with him
[Music  ]
and we are very sad to know that
another one of those conditions where he
died there, of
course, people
who like fishing with dolphins,
the carambas club, are 18 more spec
I want her not to belittle others and if she
puts it there missing that someone kills he
will be missed
a lot a lot of people will cry every second
[Music]
only he felt you guys will also
get hot at
this time but at least four o'clock
until 6 o'clock I make coffee  it's my
banana made my sandwich for me at the
rate since fishing in the bars it
's how she wants me to stay there in the
water on a motorcycle the boy who is the old
penguin is
really easy i feel very gratifying to be
able to tie being part  still of this
generation that those who live with the help
of the play a boto na em laguna we give
a lot of focus and will feel doing
on the issue of fisher abortion
one of the missions of the environmental military police
is also to carry out this
inspection on the ocean coast to
identify four whales  it is fantastic
these animals are managing to come
here and they are reproducing here in a
satisfactory way for people conservation
[Music]
also shows that we are acting
not in the favour.  The correct way that
[Music]
is to be able to visualize a boto as we
can today also count with
ease and with this freedom without
being a prohibited gear it is
extremely gratifying it's aaa the
approximately four bikes here when
boot appears it's a joy because it's
another day that  is passing along
with us so this is a sign that they
are still here in our pond there is the feeling it
is better possible because you know they
are reading an animal that will bring practical benefit
good now I'm going to go fishing right
[Music]